in the opening scene we see a family
sitting in their Garden enjoying the
warmth of the sun Bill the father and
his second wife Kim watch over their
children Brad and Dawn who are playing
in a mini water tub Bill tells his son
not to bother his sister but the little
boy rudely replies that she is not his
sister in reality they are step siblings
as the kids play Brad abruptly brings
out his private part and then asks Don
to show hers moments later Brad cries
out in pain as his finger appears to
have a cut seeing this the parents
chastise Dawn believing that she bit him
and boy they're gonna find out you know
the scene then cuts to several years
later and we see Don is now a grown-up
college student she is actively involved
with a Christian abstinence group named
The Promise the main objective of the
group is to promote the idea of waiting
for the right life partner before
engaging in Intimate Relationships Don
asserts that intimacy before marriage
makes the person impure during one of
her speeches Don's attention is caught
by a guy named Toby whom she finds
appealing later on her friends introduce
her to Toby who turns out to be another
member of the abstinence group the two
appear to be instantly drawn to each
other but they don't express their
feelings for now I give it two days
before they bail on the promise the next
day Dawn rides her bicycle to school
while walking inside she faces bullying
from fellow students due to her advocacy
for abstinence look at her she's not a
skank loser we're such skanks Ryan who
has a crush on her attempts to approach
her but the bullies intervene and push
him away later in the class the students
are taught about human reproductive
organs since the school is conservative
the diagram of female reproductive
organs is covered by a sticker seeing
this Ryan asks for its reason but the
teacher simply tries to brush it off
saying that it is the school's rule when
the student is unconvinced Don asserts
that women are different from men as
they are born with a sense of modesty
hearing this the entire class makes fun
of her except for Toby who stands up for
her at home Don's mother has been unwell
for a while now and her father is taking
care of her on the other hand her
step-brother Brad is now every spirited
man who often brings his girlfriend
Melanie home to make out Brad also
enjoys teasing Dawn consistently
startling her for his own Amusement one
day after school Don and her three group
friends decide to attend a movie upon
their arrival they realize that the
movie they had initially planned to
watch holds an R rating as a result the
group ends up watching a film intended
for kids for the R-rated one they could
just catch the recap whoa during this
the other two friends begin making out
leading to Toby and Don feeling
uncomfortable they simply avoid eye
contact and continue watching the movie
Once the show is over the four friends
head to a lake that consists of a cave
it is a known spot for where couples
spend their private time together while
the two friends opt for a swim Don and
Toby settle by the shore for a
conversation during their chat Don
admits that she is a virgin whereas Toby
discloses that he has had an intercourse
more than a year ago an intercourse and
now feels guilty for it later that night
Don has fantasies about marrying Toby
and starts touching herself but right
then she has a vision of a horrifying
creature which interrupts her feelings
the next morning Don arrives at school
late but she does not pay any attention
to Toby later on she calls him from the
locker room and expresses her concern
about her attraction towards him she
then shares her decision to not see him
for the time being as she doesn't want
to succumb to seduction Toby understands
her point I get it I'm freaking hot and
obligious as well in the evening Don
returns home only to overhear an
argument between Brad and his girlfriend
shortly after Melanie departs Don goes
to her stepbrother's room to talk to him
she wishes to resolve all the gaps
between them and live like actual
brother and sister however Brad rudely
makes fun of her calling her an idiot he
even invites her to sleep with him which
disgusts Don prompting her to walk away
in Anger following this she heads
towards the couple's Lake and calls Toby
who arrives there in no time the two
jump into the lake and start kissing
each other they then swim towards the
cave continuing their intimate moments
however Toby's desires intensify causing
Dawn to feel uneasy she tries to stop
him reminding him of their commitment to
Purity but he is not ready to listen as
he becomes aggressive a struggle ensues
between them with both of them pushing
each other unfortunately Dawn comes off
worse from it as she accidentally hits
her head on the ground and gets knocked
out
the opportunity Toby forces himself upon
her but as soon as he does so he screams
in pain Don also wakes up at the same
time and sees blood all over his hands
to her horror she also discovers that
his organ has been bitten off should
have stayed abstinent in your butthole
in a state of panic Toby falls into the
water while Dawn flees the scene in
Terror the next day Don is assigned to
deliver a short speech to a Christian
abstinence group but her ability to
speak is notably hindered by the
incident later Ryan approaches her and
Strikes up a conversation eventually
offering her a ride home before parting
ways he proposes a date seemingly eager
to get his dick bitten off which Don
declines due to her emotional state
later on Don unable to shake off the
traumatic incident decides to return to
the lake as she swims towards the cave
she comes across a distressing sight
insects swarming around Toby's or we
didn't oh that's now that she considers
herself as an impure person she discards
her purity ring Upon returning home she
grapple with the events details and
wonders how it happened since she knows
nothing about reproductive organs or how
they look she removes the sticker from
her Biology book and goes through it to
her surprise she learns that her organ
is actually deformed Don then uses the
internet to learn about her condition
after a few searches she finally
discovers that she suffers from vagina
dentata a condition where the vagina
contains teeth can
concerned Don makes an appointment with
a gynecologist named Dr Godfrey given
that this is her first visit to a
gynecologist Dr Godfrey exploits her
vulnerability and begins assaulting her
in the guise of an examination are you
kidding me in the process he reaches up
inside of her without a glove which
results in her panicking in her distress
her muscles react resulting in her teeth
biting off four fingers from his right
hand Dawn freaks out and runs away while
the doctor screams
yep I just yelled that and I got
neighbors while cycling home several
police vehicles pass by and Don also
notices someone driving Toby's car
intrigued and puzzled she heads to the
couple Lake to check the matter arriving
there she Witnesses police divers taking
out Toby's lifeless body from the water
this freaks Don out and she starts
blaming herself for his death when she
returns home her problems only continue
to mount her ill mother is lying on the
ground while Brad and Melanie are having
coitus nearby the what is this movie
Gone hurriedly calls 911 and rushes her
mother to the hospital afterwards she
awakens on a hospital catch and her
father sends her home to have some rest
upon reaching home she hears another
argument between Brad and his girlfriend
overwhelmed and in need of Solace she
goes to Ryan's Place seeking help she
confides in him explaining that she
could turn herself into the police
because she has almost killed two people
she also reveals about the teeth down
there but Ryan does not understand what
she is saying there's just a sticker
down there no believing that she is
stressed he allows her to take a
relaxing hot tub bath additionally he
offers her a pill assuring her it will
help her calm down while Don is having a
bath Ryan transforms his room into a
romantic setting with candles and also
Ready's a wine bottle for an enjoyable
evening a few moments later Don comes
out and searches for her clothes
intending to go to the police station
however she feels light-headed due to
the pillar Ryan had given her is
everyone in this world a freaking animal
pointing out her weakened State Ryan
persuades her to rest for a while and
postpone her visit to the police station
until the next day shortly after he
makes her lie down beside him and begins
to touch her this time Don appears to be
enjoying all of this a confident Ryan
then positions himself a Topper aiming
to make love with her at this point Don
is hesitant fearing that her dentata
might hurt him sensing her reservations
Ryan asks if she wants him to stop but
she responds now with this consent the
two of them end up getting intimate
without her unique condition involved
this makes Don realize that when she is
relaxed and is consenting to the coitus
her teeth remain inactive on the other
hand a forensic expert finds a rare
white structure in Toby's body while it
resembles a tooth from a shark or an eel
tests confirm it to be of human origin
elsewhere Dr Godfrey undergoes a
surgical procedure to reattach his
severed fingers the surgeons question
him about how it happened but he refuses
to divulge any information the following
morning Ryan and Dawn engage in Intimate
Activity one more time during the
process Ryan receives a call from one of
his friends boasting about a bet they
made on whether he could score with Dawn
he also taunts her commitment to
abstinence claiming that it was never
sacred this infuriates Don who then lets
her teeth bite Ryan and leaves with
blood everywhere Ryan freaks out and
calls his mother for help you Bobby bit
my baby later on the same day Don visits
the hospital and receives the
devastating news of her mother's passing
meanwhile at home Bill Comforts Brad
regarding his Reckless Behavior directly
blaming him for Kim's demise this causes
the two to get into a physical fight
during which Brad's dog bites the old
man on his neck as he starts bleeding
Melanie rushes him to the hospital where
they also meet Don Melanie apologizes to
Don for her mother's death and confesses
how Brad told her to ignore her mother's
cross for help earlier after hearing all
of this Don becomes emboldened by her
power and goes back home to seek revenge
she puts on makeup and goes to seduce
her stepbrother although reluctant at
first Brad gets on top of her and
engages in the coitus the next second
the teeth come out to play severing his
device and release leasing It To The
Ground overwhelmed with pain Brad orders
his dog to attack Dawn but the cheeky
Beast instead proceeds to devour his
severed my focal Gall Don then leaves
the room and Brad presumably bleeds to
death in the next scene we see Dawn
cycle away from home in search of a new
life however her bike tire sustains a
puncture in the middle of the road
forcing her to hitchhike a short while
later she gets a ride from an old man in
his car as they travel for several hours
Don falls asleep and wakes up only after
Nightfall when the old man pulls over at
a gas station Don tries to exit the
vehicle and leave however the old man
seemingly in a hurry to lose his his
dick locks the car doors and licks his
lips proposing an intimate favor before
allowing her to go don initially
hesitates but she soon turns around with
an evil smile hinting at her intentions
I'm gonna bite it right out you come on
over near me I'm gonna bite it all
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you you for
watching